can you sweat out a hangover we've
created a facility to test the world's
greatest hangover cures and we're
testing them all I'm dr. Keller Willem
doctor of internal medicine I'm Frank
Krantz I'm not a doctor but I've been
hung over a lot
welcome to the GQ hangover lab how are
you feeling pretty true people can feel
both drunk and hungover at the same I
wake up drunk a lot I want to know a
little bit about how you got here we got
some documentation that sound that's
tequila that's tequila yeah is that your
drink of choice no I just had a lot of
it you know we talked about congeners
which are all of the other chemicals in
the alcohol that make your a hangover
worse or better
tequila's kind of in the middle you know
it's not as bad as the whiskey's but
it's not as good as the vodka so it kind
of goes with the color anything
bothering you at this moment I have a
bit of a headache well Kevin you came in
we ran some basic blood tests urine
tests the urine show that they were very
dilute you're dehydrating yourself
actively we did the vitals you blew a
point one two on the blood alcohol on
the breathalyzer so you are effectively
quite drunk we brought you to the the
motor skills test which in this case is
minigolf for motor coordination Ximena
depth-perception lovely I think we just
need to get you more sober that sounds
good Kevin is drunk Kevin's Kevin's
really drunk
he's got the slurred speech he's got the
impaired balance he's got you know the
loss of focus it's all there he's got
the headache you know you mentioned his
stomach felt a little bit weird true
right right can you sweat out alcohol I
mean people say you know you didn't run
it off you know I'm gonna work it off
just to clarify you you actually don't
sweat out the alcohol it doesn't come
out of your pores what we are testing at
the root of this is if you exercise to
speed up your metabolism can you break
down alcohol or the stuff that gives you
a hangover faster so that you can you
know get it out of your body and feel
better my reservation is that look he's
still drunk he can hurt himself you know
he's already dehydrated and has a lot of
electrolyte loss yeah you kind of a
buzzkill right now you know I think this
could be pretty exciting television here
is our cure we're gonna have you get on
it ride we got this cool uniform you get
to keep this I'm not a total status I
got a vomit bucket we're gonna have you
ride for 30 minutes
I can see the alcohol coming out sorry I
was I know that's not possible let's
bring you back over there we'll check
your vitals and assess how this went
have a seat 110 over 70
play one out we beat science the
questions can you go back to the mini
golf green Kevin were basically you know
telling that your focus your depth
perception your motor skills I'm a
little disappointed in you Kevin one
shot away basically revolutionizing
science should we sit down and and
debrief I feel like I need to do yeah I
need to sit down okay yeah how do you
feel yeah well I feel fairly drunk still
you are fairly drunk still the problem
is that sweating when you're already
dehydrated from alcohol and and and
still drunk puts you at risk for
becoming you know more dehydrated and
losing electrolytes so I think that
would be my big caution here as looking
at this as a hangover cure how do you
feel about this pretty drunk still the
other thing that I want to mention is
that exercise does release endorphins
norepinephrine and the other
neurotransmitters that get released can
increase your focus and can make you
feel better I thought we were pioneers
man I thought we were gonna do something
and I thought I'd get drunk so no there
was no pioneering there if you're drunk
sweating out the alcohol I'm gonna have
to give it kind of a see because it
depending on how drunk you are it could
be dangerous but for a hangover trying
to sweat out those other toxins that
have built up I'm gonna give it a b-plus
yeah stay hydrated you replace your
electrolytes exercise is great for you
they'll make you feel better
I I agree I agree the exercise is is a
great cure for the hangover I rely on it
I'm gonna give it a b-plus for drunk I
got to give it a D I was very
disappointed and I also think it's
dangerous my cheesy illiterate
alliteration there in a rare moment of
sanity I'm dr. Keller wertham I'm Fran
Kranz thanks for hitting the GQ hangover
lab for more cures and hangover tips
subscribe to the channel or like us